um I took a net asset before this smart
hoping yeah it's a performance enhancer
we pissed testy after this too
hey what's going on everybody for first
we feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings
and today we closed out season five with
John Mayer he's a platinum-selling
singer songwriter with seven Grammy
Awards on the mantle you can catch him
on the dead and company's summer tour
coming to a city near you John welcome
to the show thank you for having me how
are you at spicy food I like spicy food
yeah I used to dip tobacco and like I
used to have single malt scotch so I
think I have the palate so you're
confident going in yes which is always a
recipe for disaster
[Music]
all right take it easy I talk about it
yeah of course I get dark it's like a
mole a almost
[Music]
so there's a lot of lore surrounding the
John Mayer songwriting process and
you've been very generous about pulling
back the curtain on that whether that's
to the Berklee College of Music or to
your fans on Twitter how do you
intellectualize the difference between
your best songs and your most famous
songs because it seems to be two
distinct buckets to you yeah I've
written songs that I really wanted to
become hits so I could not have to warm
up so much when I sang them and just
like roll into a show and be like who
says I can't get stoned you know and
it's always me so it's like the ones
that are pitched higher tend to reach
people who are then also I have this
relationship with complexity and
simplicity we're like the more simple I
think it is the more reasonable it is
for other people and the more complex it
is for me the more fun I have with it
and so I guess it is a little bit of
like a give-and-take with the audience
where I'm like this 120 chord monster is
for me this four chord thing is for the
world you know what I mean mm-hmm
but I would like to see the ones I like
the most become the biggest that would
be fine
during a 2007 column that you wrote for
Esquire you wrote about the six four one
five chord progression being a way to
hack or manufacture a hit and I'm
wondering from a music theory
perspective do you see any similar
trends in 2018 yes there's a 1 to 4
happening right now
then about it like that's probably the
most primal enjoyable chord change is a
G to a see that hold Camila Cabello
records like a love letter to like
writing pop songs with these great chord
changes and stuff and so I guess I could
hear it my might or - and then can you
give me a band that people make fun of
on the internet that you think deserves
a lot more respect from a songwriting
perspective that's a great question and
whoever that band is they deserve that I
think about it a little longer
I mean Nickelback is not as bad as the
punishment they get people ripping on
Nickelback is like when your mom used to
yell at your dad like but too much and
you were like I want to see him like get
called out but this is getting
ridiculous you know I'd like to come in
and equalize the Nickelback thing a
little bit Oh
Sheeran right now ed Sheeran here's what
happens man you go in a room you try
your best to write songs and they come
out really nice come out really good and
then what happens is they get to a point
of success where the public feels like a
market correction is to Edie Sheeran is
the official soundtrack to every uber
ride I've had in the last year and
that's not its fault
like your body is a wonderland for me
just a guy going in a room gonna hear
something that might work you know I
think we get tied to our songs a little
bit more than we might deserve
you guys were a good questions so
outside of making music you've worn a
lot of hats in your career and I'm
wondering of the following which held
the most weight for you columnist for
Esquire aspiring stand-up comedian guest
host of The Late Late Show aspiring
Santa comedian the hardest thing to
probably do
that's not let ik is getting up on a
stage and doing stand-up comedy even
harder than that is having people
already have an idea of who you are I
was a really like a collision course
thing for me was that other gifts of
people spitting up pieces of Buffalo
yeah but that was a relatively mild
situation the little chicken thing that
peeked out at me so at the time I was
going through this thing where everybody
was looking at me like a cat or lothario
womanizer
you know ascending orders of like hurt
feelings to here you know and I ended up
kind of getting off stage going it's too
hard to even fail like I'm not even
allowed to fail the way that a stand-up
should fail because I'm willing to go
through the failure mm-hmm and then
working with Dave Chappelle that's when
I realized I am a comic in more of a
passive way and then Dave is interesting
because he kind of has a foot in both
worlds too you know as much as he's a
comedy guy he'll dabble in the music and
then same with you as much as you're a
music guy you'll dab on the comedy it's
like jamming really I mean I've seen him
be on stage before for four hours
straight without an instrument he's not
singing but he's jamming I don't quite
understand how it works but it happens
and it doesn't look out of place you
know he's he in some ways is more
musical than a lot of musicians out in
the world now
[Music]
is this okay to throw away that's really
good that qualifies Sudbury remiss not
to talk about your passion for Footwear
why in your opinion is the jordan v a
perfect sneaker its historic for me
those like a car we wear it to school
and then take it I put it on the table
and I would take a bowl and I put water
and dish soap in it and I would take a
toothbrush now which is I remember the
sort of texture of that leather these
little tiny micro dots you're just like
working over those micro dots and stuff
and just trying to keep it clean cuz
that was like my car I might as well
been washing a car but my favorite is
the grape green getting funky with the
colour so that's my truth the colors do
you have a favorite shoe to wear on
stage Presto's what you're wearing today
yeah more than acronym Presto's with the
matching volt socks five colors yeah
berelson who designs racking him just
like made maybe the best silhouette of a
sneaker in a really really long time I
feel like certain sneakers outlast their
life cycle in terms of being hip and you
just can always wear and then you know
people who are really into polo they'll
have these low head meet ups where maybe
they'll trade or they'll show off their
grills are there any similar meet ups
for visiting heads that's a good
question there's not I wish there was
I'd actually legitimately like to build
it I want to see a trading post an
American sort of male based trading
posts for street wear where you walk in
and people who run it are super
knowledgeable and can say like oh that's
a 2008 visit my duck camo fishtail parka
I'll give you 600 for that someone has
to make the market and I'm not talking
about money I'm talking about importance
I would be very excited if there was a
store like on La Brea or something and
it was a second time around store but
cared about it maybe more than anyone
else did I think that would be really
cool
this is four so in 2013 you bought a
ranch in Montana and part to recover
from major vocal surgery and in part to
take some time away from the spotlight
in the sort of media self-sabotage maze
how are you embraced by the locals was
it an open arms greeting or were they a
little bit resentful of another famous
Hollywood dude seeking reference right I
can't write I just sort of realized that
the best thing for me to do when I got
out there was to say yes to every
request for maybe two years you just say
yes to a photo when you're in a
supermarket and you're wearing
sweatpants you just go yeah maybe sort
of like ideally what you want is then
when someone else comes up to ask for a
photo now four other people go leave
them alone
you know what I mean cuz they got their
photos did you do anything super Montana
like when you got out there did you buy
a big chart you build a doomsday bunker
to do anything so I along those lines I
knew that all eyes would be on me in
terms of what equipment I had for things
and what so I so I mean I could fly fish
off my back deck but I won't because I'm
the dude who will have the titanium rod
and reel and get it stuck in a tree and
people will be like you're an idiot you
just don't wanna be out there with the
six thousand dollar rig and not know
only what you're doing exactly you know
is there a regional food in Montana that
you think more people should know about
Oh elk there's a little red state in me
now you know I actually think it's just
I think it's a it's good for a human
being to understand both sides of that
life I mean out in LA everything is very
cut and dry on the binary of like we do
that we don't do that but out there it's
like you have to understand like my
friend Jeremy will come over with a pile
of elk that he gutted himself that day
and he shot the elk and he brings the
elk over and it's fantastic you know I
think I think it's really a cool way for
me to see the world now knowing that I
live in in both places
pama Chang all right
how am i doing so oh okay well I got it
yep I won't read ahead to answer your
question John you're doing great thank
you um so I fly out to Montana when I
feel like I'm turning into too much of
the thing that I don't like being like a
little bit of it's really fun and too
much of it
just has a paradoxical effect that you
turn into an alien I could be in the
middle of Hollywood on a Thursday night
like at poppy you having a party and
then Friday night be in Montana and like
look up at the TV and TMZ is on I'll be
like washing a colander if I'm these
animals and then like two hours later
back a puppy
dancing like I never went to Montana all
right John will we every crane segment
on our show called explain that grand
where do a deep dive and I guess
Instagram pull interesting pictures that
need more context so I'll bust out the
laptop I'll show you the picture and
then you just tell me the bigger story
does that sound good
absolutely all right laptop please all
right why is Justin Bieber a melody
wizard I've been in the studio with him
before and his ability to craft melodies
I've never seen anybody better his ear
is so good it's singing mallet riding
them ride him on the spot lyrics are
harder for everybody you know but him
humming him just like up off the dome
fantastic it's really really really
really good and I care about it because
when you're that gifted the reality
distortion around you is seeking to
crush that okay and you become a warrior
and like you become a warrior to try to
figure it out and fight it out so that
you can go on and make all these really
really important great records and he's
made really great music and I just look
at it like go Justin go like if you can
get through the reality distortion
experiment so that you can then be
leveled out at 37,000 feet and just make
the greatest music you're meant to make
like that's that's important to me
that's important that really gifted
people make it out of that gauntlet
guard-dog how bad can it be lips tell
part of the story too don't they they
all hit you differently you know maybe
you have a lip situation maybe you have
a throat situation you know lips just
like the treble of it the throat is like
the bass note in lips they're you know
are you liking the song so far turn the
bass up man so one saw a video of you
facetiming hot ones alum Shawn Mendes
yes in it you instantly bonded over how
uncomfortable the mercedes-benz Veon
obiano is but a lot of artists use when
they're touring overseas how they get
around I'm wondering do you think that
there's a degree to which musicians and
Nate Lee understand other musicians okay
the final one else does 100 percent
number one there's all these things that
happen to you that only other musicians
can understand we reach out to people
when it's 4:00 in the morning and we
haven't slept and we have to get up at
5:00 and now we just feel lost or the
whole thing is rigged we rely on each
other you know and I have tethered other
people to earth and other people have
tethered me to earth go and if you're
almost done you're like you become like
Mission Control for those people you
know and people or Mission Control for
me Dawson's hot sauce mm-hmm so there's
a recurring storyline these days in
hip-hop where older fans are dismayed by
younger artists not knowing about or not
caring about legendary emcees like Rakim
or Tupac is there a corollary in the
guitar music
oh yeah man the guitar music world
invented online fighting in 1995 or 6 -
things went up on the internet porn and
people arguing about the top 5 guitar
players of all time
the thing about culture now where
younger artists are getting taken to
task for them talking about older
artists is that didn't used to have so
much connection between a 50 year old
guy and a 20 year old I would think in
the past
you just let kids talk but everyone's
listening now everyone's in the same
room everyone's in the same room I think
that's gonna take a long time to adjust
to you know I I'm a big defender of
letting young people say stupid [ __ ] you
know if you could collaborate with any
SoundCloud rapper who would you clapper
I like a little boom I like a little
boom there's something about a little
boomer really like his samples are these
really highly melodic things and on a
songwriting level he says he's on page
50 on pornhub looking for a video and
then he says last year got a starter
code for Christmas and the thing about
songwriting is I like taking two
seemingly opposing ideas putting them
next to each other and letting him sort
of beat off one of another I just I
don't know why I scrolling page 50 porn
you know last year got a start a code
for Christmas it's like yet to tell us
what's on your mind man all right this
is where we're starting to get in a
really shitty graphic design oh man here
we go the color just does not look yeah
no this tastes like a tire fire all
written right I got it
the die has been cast off the game board
we're not on the map anymore we're off
the grid family um I took a net asset
before this smart loving yeah it's a
performance enhancer we pissed testy
after this - I think that is someone's
piss test hey that's a college piss test
do you ever Google image John Mayer
guitar face no but I'm understand what
you're getting at I know what people
think about it and actually I'm nowhere
near the worst guitar face that ever
existed I think I'm the most popular
guitar face everybody sit well John it's
interesting that you say that because
what we've done is we've pulled a
handful of the most iconic guitar faces
ever so I just want to show you some
guitar faces and then maybe we can crown
a guitar face king by the way I have a
lot of experience with being highly
uncomfortable in these situations with
like first dates and like so my ability
to connect with you right now I've been
here before
that's good that's good so tell me about
your dad
okay so guitar faces guitar face and I
defend them all please because guitar
faces are involuntary there's something
about the sympathetic pulleys and wires
whatever's happening in us that doing
this the only way to get the note out is
to go but here's the thing you have to
believe at least as far as I'm concerned
I don't feel it I don't know I'm doing
it in fact there are times I'm sure I'm
not doing it I look back I'm going
I don't feel it does the eric clapton
one look familiar
clap is the most respectable guitar face
maker Kito the lean back
he doesn't scrunch his eyes that's
what's important it's the scrunching of
the eyes that gives the appearance of
pain that other people are gonna go come
on how hard is this Clapton's got more
of an easy lay back into it he's
definitely the coolest guitar face maker
when it comes to chilling the Printz
guitar face the Printz guitar face I've
never mistrusted and I don't know that
you want to see it any other way what
would happen if Prince was playing the
solo while my guitar gently poke her
face gone I don't know that you want it
Joan Jett Joan Jett that's maybe the
rock and roll coolest guitar face that's
a power chord guitar fix mm-hmm she's
chunk enough power there's a difference
between the chords I think sighs I think
if you're a little more like like you'd
sort of like downshifting in the car
just up bro you have more time to think
about your face I'm not saying it's
convoluted there's definitely more time
to be because you're like you know doing
the power chord thing when you're trying
to bend a string and keep it up here and
make it go I don't know why you feel
like this gets it there that's
definitely made for a photograph Stevie
Ray Vaughan Stevie Ray Vaughn is the
most intense guitar face that ever
existed
I think Stevie Ray Vaughan had the
greatest guitar face of all time that
was all muscle it was just absolute
brute force guitar playing it but also
super sweet at the same time lovely John
all right we can lose the laptop okay oh
man
almost coughed do my nose there
starts to affect memory it does start to
affect I'll say that
[Music]
not bad on the outside Oh inside check
it out its briefcase popping the latches
or do you got in there Oh stainless
steel medical devices all right and wave
them around there in front of me a
little bit
what's the rest of my day like after
this so if I'm expected
wherever you are right now you're in the
eye of the storm you're going to be
better from here two bytes will do it so
John you're a man of many talents but I
think right up there with the guitar
plain is your ability to make
observations about food did you receive
any blowback from this tweet peanut M&Ms
are plain plain M&Ms are sensational
yes it was a real divisive thing to say
because there's some real peanut M&M
aficionado is out there and you got to
understand that to my taste a peanut M&M
is not an M&M with a peanut in it it's a
peanut with a little bit of mm around it
and I think that's what I want people
know and I feel like when I heard myself
say that I changed a couple minds on
that you ever say someone's ball feels
good coming out of your hands and you're
like this is a swish well while we're on
the topic of food how has your Ryder
evolved from your first tour to your
current tour the one thing that
everybody needs to understand is that if
somebody has on their right or furniture
and like drapes that is actually not a
diva request that's fully practical
because they're in locker rooms well I
think that there's a big disconnect I
think that a lot of people think that
the artists only room are the artists
only spaces are these nice palatial
spaces but they're actually not you're
in the away locker room you know what I
mean you want to be in like the room
before that the one before that is nice
but the actual song room is not great
and it has a sort of olfactory echo of
balls so that's not crazy but remember
also like everything you put on a rider
some kid has to go get it
all so I could drink it and that was one
that ladders are just a way to get free
free booze probably not free but all
right John okay
this is the last dab we call it the last
dab because it's tradition around here
to put a little extra on the last wing
you don't have to holy [ __ ] if you don't
want to it's volcanic behind everything
you do and say is this little quiet
implication don't be a [ __ ] your email
address is Shawn don't be a [ __ ] at hot
ones dot-com dumb can we change that
domain it's in it's in everything you do
in every move you make don't be a [ __ ]
there it is is that good that's good
that's good that's good
expect a lot of gerd tonight mainly bad
it's silent reflux 40 now so I have GERD
you know I have a medicinal pillow you
do I have a medicinal pillow ladies love
it
I face lime all right John Mayer well
here we are at the top of spice mountain
just one more obstacle and like today's
meal it's an obstacle that we're going
to take on together
well somebody hit me with the ukuleles
it's a song off you go John so what I'm
going to do is I'm gonna sing you a
little song about hot sauce right off
the top of the dome and then if you'd
like you can return the favor with a
serenade and then we'll just send the
people off on season five for good does
that sound good John mm-hmm all right so
I was actually inspired by one of your
pieces when I wrote this okay bitter
heat these wings will be the death of me
I don't want to but I need to its death
wings in an interview at the same damn
time you see it interview should never
hurt this bad ate to bomb on chicken
wings and now I'm feeling sad when drop
at a time that's what the bottle says
Mad Dogs says feel alive so why am I
feeling dead
you've been generally born that's what
the disclaimer says and now my buttholes
on fire this is an emergency
hot wings I thought it was fantastic how
much is that gonna cost to clear yeah no
do you think if we parody it will be
okay you're okay with parity loss I
think I am just saying this ain't
bittersweet
this ain't bittersweet totally was not
inspired by bittersweet the same this is
you and me we do a slow pull in yeah he
already doing it it was heartfelt it was
inspiring the sweat that you see on my
face has nothing to do with the hot
sauce that's a tear going down my cheek
John Mayer and I am so proud of you from
the other side of the table clearing the
chicken wings and then hitting the
people with a song to send us off now
there's nothing left to do but roll out
the red carpet for you John Mayer let's
touch uke's
this camera this camera or this camera
let the people know what you have going
on in your life me yeah am i plugging if
you own a Grateful Dead shirt get it
registered by going to a dead and
company show this summer don't wear a
Grateful Dead shirt and not go see the
guys from Grateful Dead play music this
summer if you want to immediately be
immune from ridicule from your friends
and other deadheads from wearing a
Grateful Dead shirt without knowing a
single song you can end it immediately
by going to one of the 25 dead and
company shows this summer and
effectively registering your t-shirt by
buying a ticket thank you very much
everybody
[Music]
some ukulele players gonna watch it be
like he's tuning that [ __ ] thing up
like to you to overachiever
[Music]
oh wait guitar phase one dab to dab
three dab what the what this is Sean
Evans checking in from a wingless table
and you know what that means we're proud
to announce a new member of the last dab
family Trinidad's famous Moruga scorpion
pepper the hottest pepper in the world
from 2012 to 2013 is now in the fold
same base recipe and no one loved but
now with a new super hot in the mix and
I know that one of you spice Lords out
there is going to hit the triple dab the
scorpion into the Reaper into the pepper
X you know the drill heat nice calm by
it while supplies last
Godspeed spice Lords be careful out
there